بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم في اليوم الثالس
للحرب الدمويه على قطاع غزه وفي ظل ارتكاب
الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي الى مئات المجازر بحق
المواطنين العزل في قطاع
غزه
وايضا نزوح عشرات الالاف من المواطنين من
منازلهم نتيجه استخدام الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي الى اساليب التهديد والقتل
وسياسه ضرب
ايضا
سجلنا مع وزاره الصحه اكثر من
22600 شهيد وما يزيد عن
57000 جريح جلهم من الاطفال ومن النساء
ومن كبار السن حيث ان اغلب الجرحى هم
بحاجه الى العلاج بالخارج والكثير منهم
ربما يستشهد في اي لحظه نتيجه الواقع
الصحي الصعب الذي تعيشه مستشفيات قطاع غزه
في ظل الاحتلال الاسرائيلي وفي ظل عمليات
الاستهداف
والقصف لقد عملت طواقم الدفاع المدني منذ
بدايه الحرب على قطاع غزه على الاستجابه
لالاف المناشدات ونداءات الاستغاثه والعمل
بكل الامكانات
المتاحه على انقاذ عشرات الالاف من
المواطنين من تحت الانقاض وانتشال ايضا
الالاف من الشهداء ممن استشهدوا في
منازلهم من جراء القصف الصهيوني على
المنازل الماهوله بالسكان في قطاع غزه لقد
تعرضت طواقم الدفاع المدني في قطاع غزه
لعده مرات من
الاستهدافات المباشره والغير مباشره حيث
قدمت المديريه العامه للدفاع المدني منذ
بدايه الحرب حتى هذه اللحظه 43 شهيد وما
يزيد عن
180 جريح اغلب هؤلاء الجرحى بحاجه الى
علاج بال الخارج وهناك ايضا من بترت
اقدامهم اثناء قيام قوات الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي باستهداف المناطق التي كانوا
يعملوا
بها ايضا لم يكتفي الاحتلال الاسرائيلي
بهذا فعلى مستوى المركبات والمعدات فقد تم
استهداف اكثر من
70% من مقدرات الدفاع المدني وهذا استهداف
تركز في مدينتي غزه والشمال وعلى مستوى
المراكز ايضا فقد دمرت قوات الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي عشر مراكز من مراكز الدفاع
المدني ما بين دمار كلي ودمار جزئي بليغ
من اصل 18 مركز على مستوى القطاع وهناك
عده مراكز ايضا خرجت عن الخدمه نتيجه
تواجد قوات الاحتلال الاسرائيلي
بمحيطها على مستوى المعدات الثقيله فقد
تعمد الاحتلال الاسرائيلي بقصف الحفارات
والجرافات التي كانت تستخدمها طواقمنا في
عمليات انتشال الشهداء والجرحى من تحت
الانقاض الامر الذي ادى الى بقاء جثث الاف
من الشهداء تحت الانقاض حتى هذه اللحظه
والذي يقدر عددهم اكثر من 8000 مفقود
اكثرهم من الاطفال ومن نساء ومن كبار السن
وهناك اعداد كبيره ايضا لم نستطع الوصول
اليهم من الشهداء نتيجه تواجد قوات
الاحتلال الاسرائيلي والياته في عده مناطق
في قطاع غزه الامر الذي يمنع طواقم الدفاع
المدني من التقدم والوصول اليهم نتيجه
تواجد قوات الاحتلال الاسرائيلي مع العلم
ان الاتفاقيات الدوليه نصت على حمايه
طواقم الدفاع المدني ودخولها الى هذه
المناطق لكن الاحتلال الاسرائيلي يضرب
بعرض الحائط كل الاتفاقيات وكل المعاهدات
الدوليه ايضا بالنسبه الى البنيه التحتيه
فقد تعمد الاحتلال الاسرائيلي الى تدمير
البنيه التحتيه في كافه المناطق التي دخلت
اليها اليات الاحتلال الاسرائيلي وايضا
المناطق التي تم استهدافها من قبل طائرات
الاحتلال الاسرائيلي هناك تعمد واضح لدم
البنيه التحتيه بشكل كامل هذا الامر اثر
على حركه طواقم الدفاع المدني من الوصول
الى اماكن الاستهداف التي نتلقى نداءات
استغاثه من المواطنين منها وهذا الامر زاد
ورفع عدد الشهداء الى ما تحدثنا به ايضا
لم يكتفي الاحتلال الاسرائيلي بذلك فقد
اعتقل خمسه من عناصر الدفاع المدني وحتى
هذه اللحظه لم نعلم عنهم اي شيء وبناء على
كل ما سبق فاننا في المديريه العامه
للدفاع المدني في قطاع غزه نطالب بالتالي
اولا نطالب المجتمع الدولي وهيئه الامم
المتحده ومنظمات حقوق الانسان الى ضروره
العمل الفوري والعاجل الى ايقاف هذه الحرب
الدمويه التي تشن على قطاع غزه والتي تهدد
كافه مرافق الحياه في القطاع
ثانيا نطالب اللجنه الدوليه للصليب الاحمر
واللجنه الدوليه للحمايه المدنيه الى
ضروره التدخل الفوري والعاجل لحمايه من
تبقى من طواقم الدفاع المدني من القصف ومن
القتل ومن عمليات الاستهداف الاسرائيلي
ثالثا ندعو المؤسسات الدوليه والمنظمات
الانسانيه الى ضروره العمل على ايفاد جهاز
الدفاع المدني بالكوادر البشريه وم الدول
العربيه والتي من شانها تساعد الطواقم
الموجوده هنا في قطاع غزه في البدء
بعمليات انتشال الجثث الموجوده تحت
الانقاض والتي لم نعمل على انتشالها نتيجه
عدم توفر الامكانات والمعدات التي
استهدفها الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي رابعا نطالب اللجنه الدوليه
للحمايه المدنيه والامم المتحده بضروره
ادخال سيارات دفاع مدني من اطفاء ومن
انقاذ ومن حفارات وجرافات وايضا اسعاف حيث
ان العجز الحالي والمطلوب حاليا توفيره
الى قطاع غزه وبشكل عاجل 18 سياره اطفاء
و1 سياره اطفاء انقاذ و1 سياره اسعاف ايضا
الى خمس حفارات وخمس جرافات وايضا خمس
سلالم هيدروليك وعش صهاريج مياه تزويد
سيارات
الاطفاء
خامسا ضروره توفير المعدات اللازمه لحمايه
المواطنين في قطاع غزه وخصوصا معدات
الانقاذ واهمها اجهزه التنفس واجهزه كشف
الاحياء تحت الانقاض والمعدات
التخصصيه التي تختص في مجال العمل في
انتشال الجرحى والشهداء في المنازل التي
يتم استهدافها
من قبل الاحتلال الاسرائيلي سادسا نؤكد ان
الدفاع المدني في قطاع غزه لم يمتلك اي
كميات من الوقود والتي بناء عليها تم
ايقاف اكثر من 70 في من قدرات الدفاع
المدني التشغيليه